welcome everybody my name is matthew
kaiser and today i will be talking about
dna star software
and analyzing some variations in a
cancer data set
uh we'll start today with a little
introduction to dna star as the company
dna star is located in madison wisconsin
uh we have this nice picture of a
summertime shot i guarantee you it's
much colder than that here today it's
called iranian fortunately
but madison is centrally located if you
haven't been here before our sales team
is here our developers are here
and we've been a long-standing company
for for quite a few years
our founder is dr fred blattner
who founded
a dna star back in the 1980s so it's a
really a long-term player
in bioinformatics software
we have solutions for
life scientists
that include sanger sequencing and
next-gen sequencing platforms and we
design software for desktop computers
and and linux computers as well if
you're if you're doing uh large-scale
assemblies
and we also more recently have some
offerings up in the cloud
so
you know depending on what your needs
are we may
certainly have some software for you
so dna start software is research grade
it's been used again back since the
1980s and used for scientists to
analyze sequence data and create
publications and for the past 28 years
we have been the most cited
software company for sequence analysis
and you can see that our next nearest
competitor has less than half of the
citation so so it's really a goal of
ours to produce software
that is easy to use
yet powerful enough to
do the analysis that you need
so one of the first questions that will
come up
with desktop software is whether or not
it's powerful enough to handle the data
sets that that you may be generating
with your next-gen sequencing
instruments
and for the past few years we've really
developed some of our own algorithms
that can optimize the latest
hardware and produce very very good
assembly times and just to give you an
idea
human genome for instance
see i'll try my little arrow tool here
human genomes take about 12 hours from
start to finish time
in this assembly time of
on this computer 13 hours this is
over a billion reads nearly 40x coverage
and this is not just an alignment but
it's also a full gapping of the assembly
producing bam file outputs doing all the
statistical snip analysis
and so this assembly time is really um
you know
not just a mapping a lot of times when
we look at benchmarks it's just how long
does it take to map reads to a reference
but this is actually producing all the
output files so it's ready to go
free to do analysis so really an
excellent time um exomes are more
variable but it's roughly two hours per
exome
some of the later versions of our
software are dipping under two hours
here's a data set of eight exomes that
were assembled together and an average
is a little bit under two hours per
exome so again very very
powerful assembler running on a desktop
computer a data set that we'll look at
today is an important ampliseq cancer
panel which is a very deeply sequenced
gene panel
with a couple of million reads and the
coverages can exceed 500x and we measure
this in minutes so it's you know it's
just a few minutes through the assembly
and things like rna-seq and smaller
projects again we measure those in
minutes
so the type of hardware so so you're if
you're thinking about doing your own
assemblies um
rather than maybe having a core facility
assemble for you or if you are a small
core core and you want to produce an
output file that your researchers can
use more easily one of the first
considerations that you'll have is the
type of hardware that you need to invest
in
again our goal is typically design
software that really
is accessible to a researcher so we
design it to run on computers
that are economical you know not not
super computers that cost twenty
thousand dollars uh we shoot for
computers that cost for under two
thousand dollars
and uh and this little schematic just
shows you an optimal hardware
configuration
and so you know if after the
presentation today um you're interested
in a demo you definitely want to just
double check make sure you have the kind
of hardware in place and what we
generally recommend is a core computer
that has a processor between four and
eight cores
um you know 16 gigs of ram
and you have adequate storage this could
be on a network drive or you know it
could be a local drive on your computer
and when we're doing alignments to human
genomes really what's what's key is
having enough scratch disk space and and
this varies it can be as little as one
terabyte you know as much as four
terabytes of space
and the algorithm utilizes the scratch
disk space to
process the temporary files that are
generated during the assembly so it's
real really key to have
a drive dedicated to handling those
temporary files and in these days of
course it's economical you can plug in a
drive into a laptop
you can stick another drive i have a
laptop where i pulled the cd-rom drive
out and replaced it with an ssd drive so
i can do these assemblies on my laptop
so again
it's economical
and you can get great performance you
know the benchmarks that we're looking
at that's done on a computer that's
under two thousand dollars so so really
minimal hardware
to get maximal performance
another thing to consider with uh with
software is the level of support that
you're going to receive with that
software
and what i'm showing here is just a
screenshot of the dna star website and
all these you probably can't see them on
your screen but all these little green
links these are videos and you can see
some are overviews and iron torrent and
pack bio and illumina
these are videos that are generally
three to four minutes long some of the
overviews are longer and they cover
specific topics
and so
our customers utilize these heavily if
they just have a question about a
certain
um you know certain workflow they can
usually find a video in a couple of
minutes and they'll understand you know
how to do their workflow
and so as part of our our software
offering we provide support that's
online
like these videos we also do one-on-one
webinars so kind of like we're doing
today except we might look at your
project together
and work through you know whatever issue
or questions that you have so we really
provide the best possible support for
our customers
um webinars are also uh scheduled on a
about a monthly basis and and so you'll
if you sign up for a newsletter you'll
be notified of different webinar topics
some of these are next-gen topics some
of these are regular uh you know just
your basic sequence editing and announce
analysis
we had a webinar just recently on
megaline pro one of our new applications
and i did an advanced snip analysis back
in august so so these are again these
are hour long they're great to check out
so the software that we're going to talk
about today is primarily the laser gene
genomic suite
of the laserjean genomic suite for those
of you who are familiar with dna star
software includes a portion of the core
laser gene product that that we've sold
here for you know 20 plus years
plus the addition of our seekman engine
assembler that we'll look at today and
then the advanced analysis tools in
array star and we also have other
packages if you're if you're not doing
next-gen projects we have you know
multiple sequence alignment packages and
protein and structural biology and
protein folding packages so again
depending on your needs we do have
different software packages available to
you
so the the type of next-gen projects
that we support are wide-ranging
they include genome resequencing
exome and targeting re-sequencing
rna-seq lenovo transcriptome this is
just a partial list you know we do
things like viral integration sites
metagenomic assemblies and so a real
difference between
seekman engine our assembly our
assembler software and say an open
source program is that it's very
flexible so
you know if your needs are more diverse
if you're doing you know cancer analysis
plus you're doing some viral analysis or
you know maybe some some other kind of
microbial analysis
uh our software can accommodate all
those different workflows so it's really
a solution that can take the place of
many different assembly programs
so today we're going to be talking about
uh targeted resequencing and what
targeting resequencing means is you know
aligning to a template sequence and
doing variant analysis
oftentimes it's comparing individuals to
other individuals or control genome
or
or comparing sets
and
so the software has to be flexible
enough to accommodate you know different
numbers of samples and so you know for
example
uh you know you may have one or two
samples where it's just normal versus a
tumor sample which would be fairly
common in a a cancer study or a pedigree
analysis which is usually some cohorts
or family analysis and then association
studies where you're fishing for
variants of interest in a population so
you may have sequenced you know
several hundred individuals you know
exomes or
gene panels
and you want to find out you know
statistically which variants are
are interesting amongst that population
so our software has a variety of
different uh sample handling
capabilities and filtering options to
allow you to do
these different
types of analyses
so one of the first challenges with
targeted resequencing is
really filtering through
you know the massive amount of of uh
noise that can be in next-gen sequencing
data sets and a lot of times if you have
some pipeline software some of the
filters are kind of hardwired in place
you might not be aware that you know of
iron torrent or illumina data that
there's a lot of kind of
background noise and some of the
pipeline software kind of automatically
separate that and just kind of pick a
parameter what's a little bit different
with our software is we give the the end
user
all the controls so that you can run an
assembly without any filters first and
that's usually you know a nice thing to
see you know if i don't do any any
filtering at all how many variations do
i have and then you can start to apply
more stringent filters and and get a
good feel for you know when you apply a
filter um you know
where the noise drops out and where you
start to pick up signal you know is
there an overlap there is there a
sensitivity limit to
my workflow
so what i'm going to show you today i
actually spend you know a fair amount of
time i'll discuss you know how we apply
some of those filters and and how we go
from a large pool of variants down to a
much smaller pool of variants
so the workflow today is in our genomic
suite and we're going to start with some
ample seat
cancer data data sets
and we have three data sets and and
we'll align these to a human genome
reference
and this is done in our seekman engine
software so seekman engine
is the starting point uh and then the
output from seekman engine is a ban that
assembly file so i could actually have
drawn this picture differently
depending on what your needs are you may
take that band out assembly file
and go into seekman pro which is what
we're going to do today
or we could go to a race star or you
might have another program that reads
bam files and you might plug the bam
files into you know another program to
do your analysis but we're going to kind
of keep a linear flow seekman engine
will do the assembly seekman pro allows
us to visualize that assembly and do
some snip evaluation
and then array star
allows us to import you know anywhere
from one to
hundreds of assemblies and we can bring
them together you know in this case
could be cancer and control or different
individuals and bring them all into a
race star and then use a race star to
find candidate genes or snips of
interest
so we'll start in seekman engine and
what we're looking at here is the
project setup wizard for seekman engine
it's not a true program in the sense
that there's no file menus here i'm not
opening and saving files not editing
files
it's a project setup wizard that allows
me to
um to set up a wide variety of projects
with a wide variety of sequencing
platforms
and the design of seekman engine is such
that you know it's meant to be for a
novice user you know if you've never
done an assembly before i've had people
that have never worked with next-gen
sequence data and the first time that
they try sequin engine they get a great
assembly and that's really the goal we
constantly tweak this interface you know
to find any any areas that are potential
problems for customers and we just try
to make it as foolproof as possible
and while doing that we also
provide advanced options so once you're
an experienced user you can start to
make some changes and change some
default parameters to to improve your
assemblies
so we'll start by creating a new project
and we can choose the project type and
you can see here we have some viral host
integration meta genomic in 16 srna
mi rna
transcriptome and rna seq assemblies
targeted and sequencing genome
and today we're going with the targeted
resequencing and of course as you make
selections here
and so we have our selection here target
degree sequencing but if i were to
select another workflow
that actually starts to set
different default parameters in the
algorithm automatically you know a meta
genomic sort so taking data and aligning
to
5000 bacterial genomes at all at one
time is a very different assembly than
aligning sequence data deeply to
some gene target so a little bit
different flavor of the algorithm
that allows for this flexibility but you
don't need to know what's under the hood
you just click your workflow and next
and provide a project name
and of the folder for the output files
there's also a temporary file location
uh this goes back to that scratch disk
that we're talking about with the
hardware and this is the point that you
specify
the drive that you have dedicated to
handle temporary files and this is very
important it's the data flow to this
this this
drive
um really has a large impact on the
overall speed and efficiency of the
assembly so it's an important thing to
to note
then we select our input files
i've selected a dot genome template
package here
and this genome template package is
downloadable from the dna style website
so there's a link here that goes right
to our website
we create genome template packages for
all the model organisms
so we have human and mouse and rat and
pig and cow and
c elegans and arabidopsis so a whole
host of organisms
and
the genome template packages contain dna
sequences plus
db snip information
i can show you here's the
the website so we have uh zip files that
you can download
um and we update these on a regular
basis so these uh packages will be
with with
a different release cycle between genome
builds and db snip packages so you can
see here we've got the db snip build
and then the assembly name
so it's a pretty active process to keep
up with all the different packages and
and if there's an organism that you
don't have um there are still options
for you you know you can request that we
build a package for you
we also have a means of
creating a packaged de novo from a novel
organism and what these packages are
containing then is all the db snip
information the cosmic database the gert
database
and we provide this in a package so that
when the data is assembling
all this information is known to the
assembler so our assembler starts the
new statistical snip analysis
as the data is streaming through so if
you know where there's you know
reference snips you can start to apply
the statistics in that data path so it
makes it a more efficient process to do
assembly and
variant calling when you have these
packages
uh once we've selected our reference now
i should also mention
you don't have to use a genome package
you could have a set of genes that you
have targeted
another a set of amplicons and faster
genbank formats so you can use other
genomes in addition to the packages
so once you've you've specified your
your template files
then you can specify the input files and
so there's a read technology option here
and i've selected i import and then we
have some more options about how we want
to set up the project so i've loaded in
in this case some some fasta files
and there's three files here i'll call
them faz ker and sir
and these three files are in the fasta
format
and i have an option here for how i want
the assembler to
to process these samples so first of all
it's multiple samples so i check the box
multiple sample data
and then there's a button that i can
customize the sample names if needed uh
we'll also engine will take a guess
looking at the file name or the folder
name and assign a group name
and so that's how you keep track of the
different samples
and then i have an option to run these
as separate projects and what that means
is generate a separate assembly package
for each sample so maybe i have 100
samples and my intention is to go to a
race star and you know
look for snips
that are in common between my hundred
samples right so i may not look at all
hundred assemblies i just wanna
associate so i might say run these as
separate projects
right here or i might say i'd like to
look at them all together you know i've
got three samples
let's align them in one project so i can
visualize the assembly together with the
assemblies stacked up on top of one
another so it gives us some options on
on how to do that
um and so
this is an important piece in uh setting
up the project we have also i should
mention there's unpaired impaired reads
uh we can handle both if you have a
combination of paired and unpaired you
can load them in as well doesn't matter
so the assembly options then are
we have some default options and some
advanced options so again for the new
user you load your data in there's some
assembly options and i won't go into
great detail in here but there's mer
size which is common to most assemblers
minimum match percentage which really
sets the stringency of the project and
the default that 93 if i increase that
number to say 97
i've just made a much more stringent uh
assembly and that means the percent of
the read must match the template in
order to align
and so if you're going to fiddle with
one parameter
that's the one to do minimum match
percentage and that will give you the
most dramatic impact on the output
assembly so it's one nice control to
have access to
we also
provide the general employee
and that's for the statistical snip
caller and for the um for the genotyping
calls you need to provide the employee
of the genome then there's also some
advanced options so i click this button
and bring up the advanced options and i
didn't show there's layout and alignment
more knobs and dials that we could
adjust to tweak the assembly again in a
reference guided assembly it's quite
rare when a customer even has to go into
those areas you know it's got to be some
unusual aspect to a data set to to
fiddle with those parameters
but the snip options are that's an area
that we do occasionally go into and i'd
like to point this out that
um
one of the first steps in removing
sequencing noise from the data sets is
to apply some upfront filters right at
the assembly and a couple of these are
things like minimum snip percentage
so by default snips that occur at less
than five percent
are
removed from the analysis right but i
could change this i might say well i'm
looking for rare variations you know
they might only occur at point one
percent so i can
undo this parameter and put zero there
and then there's no minimum filter and
snip percentage and then confidence
threshold which is the p-score i can
filter there and you can see these are
just really minimal filters you know
this isn't very stringent but what it
does is it removes you know on the
largest data sets of whole human genome
now this can remove millions of
sequencing errors from the snip files
makes them a lot more manageable so
that's kind of the first level of
filtering again usually we just go with
the default and we don't even open up
that dialog
so once we've set up our project
everything is ready to begin
what we're looking at here is the final
window in seekman engine
and the text that's there
is a script and the script is the
instruction for the assembler
and you can see that i can save the
script as well in the upper right hand
corner and that saves out as a text file
and i can save that script file um and
use it a couple different ways one if
i'm a command line user and i am
comfortable command line i can take this
script and run it in the command line
and
there's some advantages there if for
example you need to run 50 assemblies
you know over the weekend uh you can you
can
thread multiple scripts together and run
50 different assemblies over the weekend
you know so so it gives some a little
more flexibility to some of the more
advanced users
and then when i click assemble i can
watch the progress in this window it's a
log then and i can just watch the log
and wait for the assembly to complete so
it's a nice way to kind of monitor
what the assembly is doing at any given
point in time this log will update here
in this window
and it's also something i can send to
tech support so if there's a problem in
the assembly i can send the script file
i can send this log there'll be a button
that says export the log
and that's very useful for just
troubleshooting you can see exactly you
know where there's a problem and then
correct your problem very quickly and
get you back
on your way
so one of the first things so when we're
done with the assembly there's a button
here to
um to
open the project in seekmen pro and
syncman pro then we'll take the band out
assembly file and allow us to
visualize it and start doing the
analysis and so
one of the things that we might do and
we won't talk about
structural variations very much but i
might want to look at structural
variations
and seekman pro can generate a report
based off of the alignment that was just
done
to find potential
deletions insertions and other indels
and this is an interactive report so i
can
click on a place in the report and go to
that place in the assembly and verify
you know is this a insertion or deletion
or is this a potential you know
misassembly or some other issue that's
occurring and so it gives us a reference
position length and
coverage and feature
and then we can look at use sequence pro
to actually go and look at that point in
the assembly and this is uh this is the
seekman strategy view that we're looking
at here the strategy view is kind of
like a genome browser type view
these red and green uh
lines here
are features so these are gene features
you can see there's some exons right
here
and we have a coverage histogram so this
coverage histogram which is red is a
peak of sequence coverage so you can see
we have coverage of you know 600 x deep
and
a bunch of pink colored reeds and these
pink colored reeds are reeds that map to
either side of a potential deletion
and so it's a
the seekman engine assembler will detect
that the read actually splits and maps
on either side of the structural
variation so we can go and use that
structural variation report
which interacts with this view look at
the aligned data and identify structural
variations it's got a really nice
resolution for a lot of structural
variations
it can it's a great tool for discovering
you know novel variations in your data
set
of course one of the primary interests
will be analyzing snips
and this is a multiple sample so this is
a an engine assembly that i set up where
i did not run the three samples as
separate projects
i aligned them all together in a single
project
and what we're looking at here is the
sequence alignment view now in seekman
and the sequence alignment view up on
top we have a reference genome sequence
and so this is one of the chromosomes
and you can see you know these these are
feature annotations that are all
displayed
and just below that these yellow
highlighted regions these are the three
samples
right and those yellow areas are
the pseudo consensus and so i can
collapse them all down so if i have you
know 20 samples i can collapse by
clicking on these arrows and just look
at the pseudo consensus which shows me
the snip calls that are highlighted in
blue so i can you know if i have a
certain gene of interest or a point of
interest i can quickly look and see
which of my samples have a snip at that
location and which ones do not and then
i can also expand look at the aligned
data i can scroll back and forth so it's
this interface that seekman provides
it's really quite unique it's a really
nice user experience
because i can open up all these samples
you know multiple exomes multiple panels
look at the data confirm snips and have
a high degree of confidence that in my
assembly you know i'm detecting snips
and you know not sequencing sequencing
noise
so there's uh to navigate through snips
there's a snip report
and so rather than just scrolling
through an assembly
which works okay if you're looking at
one or two genes but if you're looking
at whole chromosomes um you know it's
it's not very efficient so we also have
a snip report
and the snippet port make this a little
bit bigger for myself here
so the snipper port is
interactive with the alignment views
and so if i click on any one of these
rows which is a separate variant it will
bring me to the sequence alignment view
and i can go between different
chromosomes and we can see i'll just
draw some arrows here
but there is
filters at the top
and we have information at the bottom
and each column contains a different
piece of information about the variant
and each row is a separate variant
okay and then the filters at the top are
the controls that the user has to now
filter for some of the snips and so we
can see you know the number of snips
that are present
in
in the number of columns that are
present
and let me actually undo that
so we can see there's 37 snip columns
rejected and you know how many have been
filtered out and so we can keep track of
the number of snips that we have you
know in this view and the different
filters at the top can include things
like
depth of coverage
and we can have a minimum and max snip
percentage
as well we have
over here show
coding change snaps so i can if i have
an annotated reference i can
differentiate between snips that cause a
coding change snips that do not
um show all snips so these are snips
that are both in db snip and snips that
are potentially novel
and so by applying different filters
probability p not ref
i can really filter down and focus on
those variants of interest and what i
mentioned earlier is that what's nice
about
seekman software is that i can start
very uh with allowing almost all the
variations or all the sequencing errors
into the project and get a good feel for
you know how much sequence noise do i
have and where do i really start losing
my signal you know how much can i
actually filter without risking you know
losing some signal so
it's a really nice interface to
experiment with that now the different
rows if we start from the left we have
the mid that's the sample name
and then you know contact id reference
position the type whether it's a snipper
and indel you can see they're colored
pink the reason for that is those are
these are coding these are snips that
cause coding changes so that we actually
call them pink as well
and there's a reference base and a call
base and the genotype and the impact on
the protein whether it's in a
homopolymer
here's snip percent here
you know p-value here and what i've got
boxed in here are so some database
information that came from the genome
template package so the advantage
to having a general template package is
that you get these other columns you get
rs numbers for dbsnp
you get the cosmic id numbers you get
girp scores
and then you also get from the genbank
annotated files all the features and
this is an area that will continue to
expand
we'll mention we can bring more things
into seekman but also a race star gives
us custom importers so if you've got
files or databases that are you know
maybe your own database of information
or from a colleague or from another
source
there are ways to even bring you know
bring all these databases into our
software so again sniper port is a great
place
to filter and to
analyze snips and so of course the
databases that i mentioned are db snip
and when you when you click on the
snipper port you can go directly to
there's a hyperlink directly to that
using the rs number which is up here in
the corner
excuse me
and dbsnp of course contains all the
additional information about that
reference snip
there's also the cosmic cancer database
uh and then the the gert
scores and the grip scores are great for
because they occur in both coding and
non-coding regions and you know higher
group scores indicate a higher degree of
conservation amongst mammals um and
potentially more interesting snips when
you have these higher group scores so
again this is some of the nice database
linkage uh that we're using
right now
um but you can see with with with
seekman it allows us to look at all the
assemblies um
but when you start doing larger projects
or if i've got
several thousand snips in each one of my
samples um it's very difficult to
manually go through and you know and
look at a thousand different locations
you know it's most people don't have
time or patients to do something at that
scale
so you know back when we were developing
our human genome assembler
we quickly realized there was a need to
be able to assess the assembly and uh to
look at the snips that were found in one
version of the assembler and then make
some improvements and see you know did
it get better is it the same
and and again look at those variations
look at curated
hat map data sets you know
exome and genome level you know to make
sure that we're finding all the snip so
we you know you want to develop
something that's that's highly accurate
as well
and so
we developed some tools in array star in
house array star has a lot of capability
for importing data files that are in uh
you know tab delimited format for
instance right so we can we can import
projects into a race star and it can be
you know i say 2 to 200 we haven't
tested above 200 but there's no reason
to believe it can't go above 200 what
our largest data sets are right now
and you can see i imported my three iron
torrent ample seat cancer panels
i could bring in and set this experiment
up more sophisticated if i want and so
there's a little button up here
in a race star and it says that allows
me to import attributes you know for
these experiments so so i can go to a
text delimited file and and
point to that and it'll bring up this
wizard to say well what you know which
columns are interested and this looks
like a control that i've used for my
control set here some different ethnic
groups of human genomes
and so so i can bring in all different
experiment attributes by defining um
my data files that way
array star then allows me to you know
filter across multiple samples now
at much larger scales
and so it has its own filtering dialogue
and what's very different about a race
star though is up here in the corner
i can filter
at two different levels
i can filter at a gene level or it can
filter at a snip level
so array star has
keeps track of things at gene level so
for instance
it might not be the precise position
within a gene that's of
a particular interest i just want to
know which genes have you know
non-synonymous snips occurring in them
or
you know non-synonymous snips that
introduce frame shifts or
or
make
nonsense
and so i can create a filter and get
gene sets now an array star and then
start doing analysis on genes
so i have a couple different ways i can
filter gene level or snip level
and usually what we do with the ray star
is apply filters and create interesting
sets and that's kind of what i've done
here is i've applied a
snip level filter
and i picked uh one experiment here of
my three and i just said show me all the
non-synonymous snip so here's my
filtering that i did
and i also said give me a p-value of at
least 90 and the depth of 25.
all right i said find all the snips in
the phos sample that meet these criteria
and down here in the corner of the
window
there's 150 snips that meet that
criteria and here's a table now that
subset of snips i can see things like bb
snip rs numbers and group scores so so i
can save that information by clicking a
little icon here so that's and save the
results and use all the you know
interesting snips for this sample and i
can do the same thing for all the
samples
um and and create sets of snips with the
same filtering criteria and then i can
start to compare it might be control
versus cancer sets so it's a really nice
interface for creating these gene or
snip sets that i can then compare to
each other
and so here is a
a snip table that i've created
and
so i can analyze those snips from the
sets that i created
and populate the columns now with some
additional information
and so this is different than the
seekman report in that now
i have a summary at each reference
position so you can see i have a a
snips in the k ras gene highlighted
and so i have a girt score a relatively
high grip score a reference sequence and
then i get the variant call for each of
my three samples so here's my my two
samples now are here
you know so again for a gene panel like
the i this ion torrent ampliseq panel
you know this might be all i need i just
may have a handful or a few dozen
samples and i know what gene i'm looking
at i just see you know who's got the
snip and who doesn't
i can also import additional information
so you see these extra columns here i
have a clinical association a polyphen
allele count observed genotypes and you
know my screen wasn't big enough but i
could include more columns this
information
i imported into a race star using one of
the custom import wizards and this came
from actually this came from a vcf file
from an exome variant server in the vcf
file
is annotations associated uh you know
with specific with specific
snips
and so if you have vcf files you can
bring them in and they'll contain all
sorts of information in this case
clinical association that's a link to
omim
um and then we have some polyfin
information
so you know if you're pulling in this
other information array star has quick
links
to port that information into your
project to facilitate analysis
and then once i create sets that are
interesting
i can compare them to each other i like
to do venn diagrams
which are very simple so again these are
three data sets and i can bring a
control in
and look at things you know
snips that are just in the
cancer data sets but not in the control
or snips that are in common between all
three
and there's quick links down here in the
bottom right where i can then convert so
if i do a snip search and find snips i
can say well now show me the table of
snips or i could say you know show me
the table of
genes so i can i can cross over from a
snip level to a gene level and in a race
star then i can bring in database
information that's linked to the gene
level
and so gene level information again can
be a number of different things
i'm showing a couple different options
for gene level annotation this go id
a race star has built in connections to
the go consortium for all different
organisms and that will bring in things
like ontology terms so these are all
functional and structural type links of
information so we can bring that are
associated at the gene level
so i can automatically port that into my
eraser project and then these last
columns out on the left our right hand
side are this is just a custom file that
i made
and what it was is a set of genes that
are known to be involved with prostate
cancer
and
so i loaded this file in again with the
custom import wizard and i can see that
in my my search here my gene set that
one of the genes um
is showing up also in my uh my gene list
so it's again a great way to
you know compare your filtering results
in our a-star with known genes of
interest you know in for your type of
analyses
so again that's just um another place i
could go is things like ontology
i don't have uh don't plan on showing
that today
but that's a place that we could go as
well
so just a little bit of a summary now on
on dna star software
the software is very flexible you know
that accommodates different sequencing
platforms and different types of
workflows
we run great on budget computers we run
up on the cloud you can run our
assembler on a linux cluster if you want
um and and really we shoot for desktop
computers that are
relatively inexpensive so you know under
uh two thousand dollars will get you all
the hardware that you need and we do all
different variant and genotype calling
um using bayesian statistics uh and
calculate p values and that's all done
up front in the assembler
and you know we get uh can enrich our
reporting with dd snip and cosmic incur
vcf files custom files that you may have
you know you can import those as well
as well as gene files that contain
important gene lists and and we can
compare the variants you know at all
different scales it can be a couple of
samples hundreds of samples
it's easy to use and you know i'd
certainly recommend trying out a demo
the software if you haven't already and
and
at this point i think i'd just be happy
to take some questions
and
i can stick around here and and answer
any questions and if we don't have time
today we can certainly do questions uh
through email
thank you
you